Senator Josh Hawley who we thought we
were going to get in studio today it
doesn't look like it's going to happen
because it's so crazy he was out in the
Capitol here's something he had to say
about this past election and what has to
happen with the Republicans now I think
that this election was the funeral for
the Republican parties we know it the
Republican party is as we have known it
is dead and voters have made that clear
and in particular the folks who did not
vote for republicans in this last
election were independent voters working
class independent voters folks who voted
for President Obama Once Upon a Time
folks who then voted for President Trump
but stayed home this time
we are not a majority party unless we
can appeal to those voters
yeah I mean he's not sugar coating it
he's saying the Republican party is dead
now I I don't think it's dead to such a
degree that he's saying mayor but we
don't have to split hairs on the on the
verbiage exactly the point is the
Republican party has a huge opportunity
right now
huge opportunities right now if it did
not go the way you wanted it to go
roughly a week ago
uh even though okay you got the house so
there are some good moments here right
but if it didn't work out and you got to
look at those Independents and those
working-class people it's like you got
an argument if you're Donald Trump you
absolutely have an argument hey it was
better when I was when I was doing it if
you're around DeSantis you got an
argument look at everything I've done in
Florida and I won by 20 points so there
is a rich opportunity now for
republicans and I think the more that
they grab the mantle of hey we are not
here to solve all of your problems I
know an awful lot of people a huge
amount of people way too many people
they just want more stuff from the
government right that is the that is the
Democrat promise and there's a whole
bunch of people who don't understand why
that's not really the American way so if
40 of the electorate just wants more
stuff they want higher taxes so that we
can take from some and give to others we
have to accept that that is reality and
we can wake those people up when we can
but it is not in the American ethos we
have to return to something like Ronald
Reagan was talking about in the 80s
which is that government is the problem
not the solution